the streets of minsk
belarus's capital filled with protesters
chants of change and long-lived belarus
resounding through the city
riot police pushed back against the
demonstrators
deploying water cannon and firing tear
gas and rubber bullets
incumbent president lukashenko had
warned he would crack down
on any unauthorized rallies
follow the law and any talk of
repression will disappear
the law is above all else if you break
it we will respond
and we've been light-handed in our
response so far
to be honest with you i've always held
back our law enforcement
i told them there's no need for a heavy
response
the protests kicked off after a state
exit poll said lukashenko was far ahead
many of those in the streets believed
the government rigged the results
their concerns were echoed by opposition
candidates with lana tikanovskaya
who rejected the early vote count
she said quote i believe my own eyes
the majority is with us
long lines formed outside polling
stations on sunday
with many voters sporting the white
armbands that are a symbol for
tikanovskaya's supporters
this election poses the first serious
challenge to lukashenko's 26-year rule
with support for tikanovskaya growing
over the last few weeks
she emerged as a leading opposition
figure after her husband was barred from
running
prompting her to stand as a candidate
she is now refusing to accept the feat
despite official numbers showing
lukashenko with a huge lead
and his determination to keep a firm
grip on power
for more let's bring in manuel zaratine
from hamburg he's a
member of the german parliament's
foreign affairs committee and the green
party's parliamentary spokesperson for
eastern european
policy thanks for being with us mr
salvation
let me start by asking you about the
electoral commission
in belarus saying that that lukashenko
won around 80 percent of the vote
do you think that's a credible result
you know it's quite obvious that since
25 years we haven't seen free and fair
elections in belarus at all
but i think not any election before has
been
as much fake as this one i think that
it's a clear fake election and
even not because an election now people
took to the streets all over belarus to
protest
the election result uh human rights
organizations are saying one person has
been killed what do you make of the way
the police
have responded to the demonstrators
i expected actually that lukashenko will
use force and violence to clean up the
streets to not have a
situation like in ukraine or in armenia
and it's clearly that his legitimacy has
been broken to a certain extent
in the before years we always had the
impression that there's much more
sentiment against him and a much higher
opposition than official polling is
showing
but that he might have a major return in
the country at all in any way
and this seems to be different this time
and i think that the west at european
union and also berlin
has been wrong and being too soft in
approach to lincolchenko and believing
this
towards the west i wanted to ask you
about that because i was looking at your
twitter feed and uh
reacting to lukashenko's announced
victory you tweeted that
the elections in belarus should be a
lesson to
berlin and brussels what should germany
and the eu
learn from this you should learn clearly
that
the idea that lukashenko would save
belarus independence from russia or
union state of russia and belarus which
is in debate since 25 years
is a fake argument by lukashenko and the
kremlin
to hold us as i would hearing
and we should see clearly that our only
partner can be the democratic opposition
and the democratic movement in the
country
and if belarus really clearly wants to
change a course for more openness to
what's best it must be on a
value-based approach
how would you suggest that germany and
the rest of the european union should go
about bringing in
belarus into a closer relationship with
the european
union that uh based on relations with
those opposition parties
i think the first point is even if it
seems to be naive
we need to put in the full regime of
sanctions again after we saw that
lukashenko was not holding his promises
regarding the elections
the european union has to pay attention
and we also have to be clear that with
this person in power
an openness of the european union may
not be possible he is only a corrupt
puppet
of the kremlin playing the game as
national
leader of a country which is trying to
sustain a sovereignty
while in the backhand paying
and selling out the country towards
russian interest
this must be clear a path towards the
west of belarus
will be not possible with such
president acting in this way against a
democratic opposition
mr salazin thank you very much for
talking with us that was manuel at
salvation member of the
german parliament